foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Ty uh the Warriors my Golden State
Warriors took a took a little bump in
the road last night it's a little bump
in the road last night Ryan your Celtics
took a little bump in the road in game
one and uh today today
it's a brand new day go ahead can I
address something real quick so I don't
usually like to read private messages
but sometimes somebody makes makes me do
that so earlier I I messaged our good
friend Michael Ritter
and I said Celtics minus seven and a
half today don't think twice about it
they're gonna smoke them he goes kinda
agree with you Mike Ritter first guy in
this chat says in all caps Sixers money
line
let's figure it out let's figure it out
[Laughter]
that's how we're starting the show today
Greg that's that's that's how we're
starting the show today my man Mike
Ritter is in the comments screening uh
what do you say uh Sixers money line
Joel embi is playing
they're saying that Joel embiid is back
well let me welcome everybody to the
show my name is Greg Ivory next to me to
you guys right
it's the man I like to call MB he is the
man of the app and next to me also but
to my left or to your left of the screen
uh we have producer producer Ryan is in
the house uh make sure you guys drop
your Best Bets for us tonight's game in
the chat we are talking 76 76ers and
Ryan's Celtics Ryan talk to us what are
the people talking about in the chat
oh this guy's trying to this guy's
playing games with me to start this show
all caps Mike Ritter responds change of
heart Philly till I die
let me remind you let me remind you that
you did this once this year with this
same city so you kind of deserve this
well all right jumping around too much
but you were a feeling till I die guy in
the last fall so yes no
I can't get back on my flight to New
York guy that's not till I die it was a
Philly till I until I collect my cash
and I'm on my flight home that's what I
was broke even he had a jersey he had a
jersey and everything talking about I'm
a Philly guy it was a free Church
high five and Philly fans as they walk
by like I'm saying go Birds
Dobby saying go Birds
Greg did they did they make me money yes
or no
I don't know did they they did they did
they did but
this team is losers the Philadelphia
second rounders so anyway
um all right we've got Rob Powell 15
says Maxie over one and a half threes uh
KD 8985 to Anthony Melton hitting two
threes tonight uh
he says melting two threes as well
yeah this is interesting that's pretty
hot hot stuff to come out of the gates
with and beans I did see I did see Eve
say embiid 40 plus points like we the
guy hasn't played in a whole week Man 10
days hey but he's coming off of the MVP
trophy in the you never know
a 40 ball would really surprise me in
the first game back but it is the MVP so
you got a good point there G that's what
I'm saying MVP fresh legs
I mean not fresh but you know what I
mean
like anything else in the comments Ryan
uh Tony McKenzie nb2 plus blocks
there's a lot there's a lot of MB love
um I get it he torches the Celtics but
I you know again you say fresh legs I
say damaged legs so there's a way we
have a difference of opinion there
not not fresh rested rested legs again I
would then say injured legs
leg
[Laughter]
all right well we we we talked a little
bit off air about how pathetic the the
parlays have been going recently so
instead of going big value
let's just see one go through the hoop
y'all seriously we just need to we just
need one winner
to get us to the cashier I don't care
what the odds are what do you guys think
man I'm sick of losing I just want to
check it off
I like that to be honest yeah I don't
know I was on board before we started
and then I'm and then I'm looking at
this and I'm like man I do think we
could do it this time like is it does it
will it really feel like a winner if we
kind of cheat our way to this like yes
yes
is it a point when you make a free throw
yes it's one point yeah see the ball go
through the hoop that's what we're doing
ten dollars down and you win uh uh minus
50 or minus 150 uh bet do you walk away
with money or do you not
he's right
I'm not gonna lie he's right just saying
I don't think you're right in the
context of this though like 100 he is
how not how am I not right 850. money is
20 points at least for embiid that's a
great place to start
that's a great place to start
shout out
my man knows what he's he's feeling The
Vibes The Vibes are let's go win
you're having to change your heart like
Michael Ritter
um
that's not a change of heart that's
ruining a friendship I texted him in the
middle of the show lose this number so
okay
20 20 plus points 12 and beat minus 550
first lock it in bam
all right let's go we're winning tonight
baby we're winning tonight
what about Jalen Brown is he getting
dubbed B B Money six says Jalen brown
two threes
don't hate that play either I I think
Jalen Brown has to play well if they're
gonna
you know defend home court tonight JT I
think did his thing last game I think he
had over 30 and they still came up short
when they're both going that's their
best chance to like really look dominant
and he's gonna have to have a big game
tonight
so you don't have to when we talk about
threes
do we like Jalen Brown I
I'm not gonna lie I I kind of love
Al Horford in this game I don't know why
as a Celtics fan sometimes you just get
a little bit of like that little Rumble
in your stomach when you wake up and
you're like I think this is a go ahead
you have a finger up go ahead
no keep talking I was just you're more
like orchestrating my my speech kind of
deal no no no I'm more so I'm more so
trying to let you know play the one
I'll hold her to make one three-pointer
endless Rock don't don't hate that
I thought we had chemistry bro you know
I thought we yeah
consistently on the same page and then
Here Comes Ryan agenda Ryan so here
here's my here's my deal here's my deal
I actually love Al Horford three plus
threes
you're you're you're sick no [__] like
why are we doing this like seriously
like did you wake up this morning and
was like let me take off Greg and MB let
me just throw a curveball at the whole
plan that we talked about earlier
I woke up on demon time dude dude I woke
up I had a taste of cigarettes in my
mouth still I was you know I had there I
woke up with a win but I saw a ton of
losses like I'm trying to go like we we
I want a regular win for us I do I know
I said before the show started that I
think oh you know a win is a win but I
like guys
guys this is
I'm not I'm not signing off on a parlay
that has Al Horford three threes in it I
just I'm not doing it bro why
Honestly though hey Ryan you said that
because you read the chat in all honesty
in all honesty
in all honesty you kind of have the chat
on your side kinda I said kinda I saw
some people in here agreeing with you uh
the chat's moving I can't even figure
out where where it's at oh r dot r dot
144 Al Horford three threes lock it up
Ryan I'm back love the [__] for threes
that was Michael Ritter and he's already
blocked on my phone so he can't be back
okay yeah yeah yeah all right all right
all right B Money B money also says hold
on my bad my bad hold on but B money
also says Horford three threes is crazy
just do one which I agree would be money
[Laughter]
just do one one is good come on man
let's let's
guys I'll meet you in the middle at two
but there's no way um
guys yeah I agree look at me so this is
we look during the show for months
sometimes there's a moment where you
just ask for some Trust
so when you when it loses we're gonna
we're gonna fire you up
are you up
nah you can't I can't fire you both
I think if I could I'd fire you before
we finish the show because this is
enough
hey hey can we just see what one made
three looks like we could probably meet
in the middle Ryan honestly in all
honesty we could probably meet in the
middle but like can we just see what one
made three is
bro it's we're at minus 351. like you
can't come back from that now wait now
wait who who respected wizard said Tatum
25 points that's a good play
that is throw that in there tative 25
plus points
yep all right I mean yeah all right
I'll do that he's gonna score 25.
Maybe
plus 138
okay
see now we don't need that two threes we
could just do one three you know we see
a m b I saw you I saw you working right
there I saw you working
this is so funny
uh Evie says bang our friend with this
six triple on the night
yo that would be insane
Kaden M Caden 2005 sang hard and six
plus assists love this play didn't have
as many assists in game one obviously no
one beat so he had to take a lot of the
scoring burden
he could get six and a half I think
hear me out uh-oh yeah James Harden I
like James Harden under 21 and a half
points
no
why not no because what if MB doesn't
play a full mid his full minutes he's
gonna have to score he's gassed from
game one
I feel like people been I feel like
people have slept so hard on James
Harden because he's changed his role
with the Sixers we still like that bro
he just joked he's definitely like five
but but he's like that without MB
without him being
here are you on my side
I I
kind of am Ryan not I mean
I honestly think we can go find
something we can go find something you
know more juicier
like but what do you define juicy to me
to find juicy to me do you speak to Sam
Richmond language of Juicy where that's
like minus 600 or my language of Juicy
yeah
minus 600 that's juicy like that's not
juicy that's right you're by you're
but you're buying the juice like you
don't you know what I'm seeing some I'm
seeing some hot plays man the chat is
moving Brogden over 10 points
all right we could stick on the heart
and stuff
let me tell you yeah let's stick on
harder let's stick on Harden all right
or or assists I'm cool I don't know how
that didn't make sense if I put in my
fingers like that but that's you know
that's where we're at
points what about hardened what about
Harden made threes though no no no
because I like the assist better than
the points to be honest but I really
love this Brogden play
88. 10
oh 10 plus 10 plus yep ten Place ten
plus from Bragg then he's shooting 11
shots a game in the playoffs his last
five games against the Sixers he has had
20 18 19.
I like that MB
it's a two it's a two to one parlay man
let's just let's just lock this in you
you forced us to be like that it's bald
ass so now I'm gonna force you to bet on
Malcolm Brockton we're now we're hating
on the balls Community what are we doing
wait wait hey hey Malcolm uh what's the
name uh Al Horford is Dominican so he's
he's a part of my people so I get to say
what I want
okay I don't know I don't know if that's
how it works yes
if we take it look at that that's a
hundred let's go yeah that looks even
more lovely
whoo let's do it that's a lock
that is El Bay says lock let's go man
let's just get to lock let's just skip a
plus 100 and do it man that's a lock hey
if you guys if you want to win money
take this parlay
we could call it the NBA bets we love
bankroll Builder parlay how's that
take the money that you win take the
money that you win from this parlay and
roll it over on your next play it's free
money you're welcome yes go ahead Ryan
thank you Greg
are we not at again I'm not trying to be
a bad vibes guy that's not my intention
here this is uh just no no just so we
can have a discussion uh are we at all
concerned that Joel embiid may not get
to 20 points for reasons no no he might
he might get 20 points at the free throw
line in my opinion hey Ryan he averages
36 in 36 points against the Celtics you
dominate the
nature of this you know this injury but
what did I say rested legs he's also
coming off
he's also coming off of winning the MVP
you don't think he's gonna try to come
out here and make a statement
his last four games against the Celtics
he's had 52-41 28 and 26.
that's a lot of points
lots of points all I know is his knees
average 15 minutes a game
all right here's well here's the
scenario here's the scenario he doesn't
play a full game we are all sick but the
entire world will be on Joel embiid so
at worst maybe we get avoided leg and
we're good
he's gonna score 20. like he's he's
going to be a part of the offense the
offense is going to be going through him
today Joel and B is going to be out
there he's going to score 20 points
we're putting in the atmosphere we're
manifesting Evie in the chat said he
literally just won MVP imagine him not
scoring 20. he would get cooked he's
right
Evie's right thank you that's what I'm
saying Ryan you got to understand this
man literally he just he just won MVP
I got yeah why you have you're the one
that's questioning them scoring 20
points I'm trying to get you to
understand like all I just want MVP all
I'm saying is if he gets wheeled out
like Paul Pierce after he pooped his
pants then like what you know we're
gonna go back
you've been trying to figure out a way
to get that word in this in this show
for weeks
2005 says still throw six plus assist
from Hardin in there no not today not
today not today
what's the number what's the number on
the six assists can you check might make
that the squad ride
number on the sixth oh sorry
all right did you forget what your job
was yeah it was like somebody else is
gonna do it
uh well plus eight and a half all right
yeah so 100 Squad ride so drop drop Six
of six is minus eight fifty bankroll
Builder
hey look at as the show goes on it went
from like plus money now it's into my
negative money yeah
sorry here should never say negative uh
yeah no no negative Vibes uh never say
that what if we changed and B20 plus
points to Celtics money line
nope why are you talking crazy what if
we do that so no yeah I like that good
that's a good suggestion Greg Greg just
Greg and I'm gonna read your mind here I
know what you were gonna say Greg was
gonna say Celtics minus eight but I'm
gonna calm you down Greg I know they're
gonna be smoking tonight but we'll go
Celtics money line instead
oh
don't worry about it dude don't worry
about it
oh that's hilarious but uh
I don't know right I don't know I don't
know
if the audience is with it hey hey Ryan
I'll say this if the audience is with it
let's ride
if do you guys think wait are you saying
add the Celtics money line to our parlay
are you saying add a Celtics money line
and take something away Orville well
Orville Martinez first comment said no
money line in a in a builder and I agree
I do not want
listen Okay no money line right I think
the audience is speaking
I think that if we were to put this in
at plus 100 or whatever it is and the
Celtics lose somehow we will literally
flip tables being so bad no sir not
today I agree I totally agree all right
I was falling for it MB but you know you
got me in my senses yeah so we're cool
with this being minus 102.
yes yes yes that's perfectly fine
that's money Ryan guys it's money we are
going to get the money be money success
we're not with it which is really funny
we get cooked every I get cooked every
post already
I know for real I know so
I had somebody told me I was gonna get
kicked out of my apartment yesterday it
was really funny anyway that's neither
here nor that let's lock this in lock of
the Year fourth fly Court 420 said lock
of the Year let's go
[Laughter]
we're locking it in Ryan you got to do
what you do best all right yeah well I
mean I I do other things better but I'll
read
um all right Jason Tatum 25 plus points
Malcolm Brogden 10 plus points Al
Horford
one plus made three if you wanted to
play three plus made threes though I
wouldn't blame you and then Joella bead
20 plus points four legs minus 102.
this can't lose
it's not gonna lose that's the thing no
chance and like we said take this money
and roll it over to the next parlay it's
free money you are welcome if you want
to tell our four leg parlay make sure
you head on over to FanDuel Ryan tell
the people what's happening when they
get to FanDuel yeah and if you're new to
FanDuel and you hop in there and you're
like oh my God
what do I do bet five dollars and get a
hundred and fifty dollars in bonus bets
so then next week after this wins you
just dump it onto the next bankroll
Builder and then we just start getting
rich together it's it's a cycle of
richness that happens
um so again new customer to FanDuel bet
five dollars got 150 back in bonus bets
guaranteed guaranteed we start
connecting dots Ryan we start connecting
dots let's go
let's talk everybody's best bet for
tonight
let's top everyone's best bet for
tonight Ryan should we start off with
you actually I'll go first
I'll do the honors I'll let you set up
and I'll let you do your Dougie I'll let
you set up and I'll do the honors just
because I
I was gonna go first just because we
were just talking about this guy Joel
embiid We were literally just talking
about him
and Ryan you were skeptical on his plank
total of him scoring 20 points you know
what I'm going to take his point total
over 25 and a half points I mentioned it
earlier he's coming off of winning the
MVP he had the speech you know what I'm
saying he he had he he he's coming off
of that momentum he's also coming off of
rested legs not fresh legs but rested
legs
I don't think that the Sixers will be
putting them out there if he wasn't
ready to go and if Joel and beats ready
to go in his track record against this
Boston Celtics team where he's averaging
36 points a game this year if he's ready
to go he's going to go score 25 and a
half points so give me Joyland beat over
25 and a half points
uh MB
you go next Ryan you round assault you
rounded off in uh that third
all right so if those people who are not
privy to the socials I am on a first
basket Journey these days
and my voice sounds a little sad but I'm
lit because I finally won again thank
God we got another Victory last night so
we're trying to we're trying to start up
a streak and I got two first basket
plays just to go inside with Greg's take
and bead kind of messed up my mojo today
my first play
Jalen Brown plus 550 on FanDuel to score
the first basket he's taking the highest
percentage of first field goals on the
team especially in the playoffs
and Beads returning and he's win and he
just won the MVP I think of the truck no
troel embiid the troll that he is he's
going to try and make a statement early
so I'm playing two give me embiid plus
430 give me Brown plus 450 or they've
changed a little bit plus 600 plus 400
those are my two plays tonight Horford
wins the tip over and beat two out of
the last three times they played so
might put more money on Brown if you
think that's the vibe those are my two
plays tonight and I'm gonna win and I'm
Gonna Roll it over and we're getting
really really rich this weekend baby
let's go
hey Rich Let's Get Rich go ahead Ryan I
love the I love the Jayla Brown play I
think that's fantastic let's go I love
it let's go over it all over it not on
the and beat stuff but
for Vibes for vibes
okay
so the floor is yours this is wild let's
let's just
I'm gonna get in front of this this is
gonna be try and follow me
exact series order of how each team wins
okay Philadelphia already won game one
there is no chance no chance the Celtics
lose tonight
0.0 Celtics to win game two and then
they travel over to little Philadelphia
right and then they stamp their mark
down and win game three then Philly says
oh my god oh my god dude we need to we
need to protect home court you can't get
swept at home so they win game four
right and then what happens then we go
back to Boston and Boston's like whoa
whoa we can't let them take the lead on
us in our home court well this is our
city and then they win game five and
then they go to game six in Philadelphia
and they say this isn't Ben Franklin
City this is Jason Tatum and Jalen Brown
City and they win game six
that's plus 1100
that well I was saying all that you're
like oh my god that actually makes that
actually makes sense Ben Franklin you
know Boston this that and the next thing
um Greg how long you think it took him
to practice that little speech in the
mirror dude he was practicing in the
mirror this morning he at least did it
three times
be honest Ryan uh over under over under
set at three and a half what do we think
we had the hand motions and everything
everything was working good okay
if you hit I'm not missing the boat so
I'll play it whatever
facts live in the comments here Ryan's
mayor is so tired of that speech
[Music]
hey uh I love the speech though right I
love I love the conviction man I hope
you could sell me the pen anytime dude
you just have this like confidence about
you when you're talking crazy that it
just like makes sense
that's the unbiased take EB says touch
it and buy a steak uh I love it I love
the black I love the right
Vibes I love our parlay today because it
is going to win we are manifesting into
the air manifesting into the chat
manifesting on the bleacher report app
that this parlay is going to win so if
you guys want to make some money
go put the parlay in and ride with us uh
Ryan
I need I need energy I need energy
listen I need something like what kind
take us home man
let's go like you're just sitting there
like you're regretting the parlay that
we put in no no I think wow I I you know
I've been thinking a lot about this MB
20 plus points I won't lie but that's
neither here nor there I'm riding off
the high of the of the plus 1100 play I
feel pretty good but I mean listen just
to to get this off my chest here uh I
really love this play but also I bet the
Celtics minus seven and a half when it
was at that number earlier I do think
that the Boston Celtics smoke the
Philadelphia 76ers tonight I think
they're gonna smoke them
what's up
you think they're covering the Sprint oh
yes I think they win in the range of 20
to 30 points would you would you would
you like to be tonight's Squad ride
leader
hey I think so I think
all right let's get it programmed this
man says are you gonna play the the
spread are you gonna play uh 20 plus
minus nine in it yeah all right okay
relax
I want my first bet yesterday in like
two weeks I'm not trying to get greedy
here we'll take the seven and a half
there you go okay be on the lookout it's
getting programmed as soon as this
show's over baby let's go here we go
there it is a lot of locks given on this
show a lot of plays giving on this show
a lot of Vibes a lot of energy uh but
it's time for us to get on up out of
here it's time for us to go win some
bets it's also time for some of y'all to
go put in those best that you got from
the show so uh
my name is Greg Ivory for Michael Boland
producer Ryan we
are out of this thing man peace
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you